[Music]
we want to know in your opinion what do
you think is the most
important action kpi metric that
contributes to recruiter's success
and the number of meaningful
conversations about clients on campus a
bit of a cop-out right isn't it the key
there is
it's knowing and understanding and
really being treat yourself and what's a
meaningful conversation did you get
something out of the call if it's
and if you're just having conversations
for the sake of having conversations
we'll see
how that goes you know you can speak to
50 people a day but if you're just
talking about the weather
or you're not actually getting anything
out of it then it's no good so
yeah it's it's the number of quality
conversations where you're getting more
information you had when you started
would your advice be to me if i'm
struggling at the moment with the
business development side like what
would you say to me that
hopefully would help me get more out of
my efforts or just help me push on your
thing
so if you've if you start your career in
this
recession this hellhole of a market
like that's the best thing that can
happen to you because if you can get
through that
you can get through anything it's
consistencies keep going through it
you just trust the numbers we always
just put faith in the numbers
of you do this enough times and you'll
be successful
bye